Okay.
Hey, what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast and
ahhh
I'm just checking in on you. How's it
going? How are you? How's your week going?
Oh, that's wonderful.
Now I know a lot of you guys last Monday
were very upset with me when I was
speaking in code and you just couldn't,
you know about my European tour.
You're like, well, wait a minute.
It rhymes with Burundian mingle and
well, where the hell would that be?
I'm not some sort of sleuth.
I can't figure that stuff out.
I got to start breaking down code.
This isn't what I signed up for.
I signed up to listen to a angry
half a Leprechaun, you know,
bitch above getting a
sunburn. Um, all right,
well I can actually announce some dates.
I don't know why I can
announce all of them.
I don't know what the
big fucking secret is.
It's not like I'm going to go over
there to start spying on you. Uh,
but here's the ones we got so far actually
that the tickets are going to go on
sale. Um, I don't even know how
to fucking say these places.
Colston C o l s t o n
hall in Bristol. Um, U K,
um,
announced five, 25 at 10:00 AM. All
right, so the tickets are on sale.
Oh, why? This is one. I announced it
Olam, announced it on the 26th. Um,
the tickets will go on sale on May 27th,
um,
at 10:00 AM B s t, whatever
the fuck that means.
Britton Standard Time. I don't know
Billy stupid tits. I have no idea.
I'm, you can get those at live. nation.com
artists slash Bill Byrd Dash two,
whatever the link is on my, my, uh, my
website. That's going to be August 3rd.
On August 4th, I'm going to
be in fucking Manchester,
Manchester, England,
home of Man United. Um,
I'm going to be there, um, on August 4th.
And uh, those tickets will also go on.
Those tickets won't say on the 26th.
That's the Presale,
um,
to sell subscribers only.
Whatever the fuck that means.
I don't know what any of this shit
means. Um, for all you normal people,
I guess, who don't have cell
phones for all the old people. Um,
tickets for everybody else will go
on sale on May 27th at 10:00 AM uh,
Billy stupid tits time. Uh, um,
August 5th, where am I going to be
next? I'm going to be in London,
England at the Apollo. Hammersmith.
Um,
these things go on sale at a once again.
May 27th at 10:00 AM uh,
Britain standard time.
God Save the Queen Time. I
don't know. I'm and August 8th,
I'm going to be at in Edinburgh, Scotland.
The folks still fucking podcast.
Uh, sorry for the bad accent. Uh,
pleasants grand two shows there. I
think I'm doing two in London too.
I can't remember. I don't, fuck. I don't,
I don't pretend to know these things.
Um, those will also go on sale on
May 27th at 10:00 AM all right.
And I got some dates. I got
three dates in Ireland too,
and I got a something in
Amsterdam. I think that'll be it.
Nice little 10 day fucking run
there. Go over there. You know,
stare at you pasty constancy.
Where my freckles came from.
That's what I'm doing. Oh, I
can't wait. I cannot fucking wait.
You know we are knee deep neck
deep into writing this season.
We've got the table right here and
a couple of hours for episode five,
episode five. Um, then we do six, seven,
eight and June and then
nine and 10 in July.
And then we fucking edit
them for the next 10 months,
not even 10 months, whatever.
For the next six months we'll be adding
in all this fucking shit and we'll
basically have them and then they'll come
out may of next year and you guys will
sit down with a six pack of beer and
you'll burn through them in about three
hours and then be like, wait a fucks.
The next one. And you know what?
We'll make you some more cause
we're having a great time,
but I'm not gonna lie to you. Um,
it has become my life and I don't
know what the fuck's going on at all.
I know that Donald Trump
was here yesterday.
I'm having a rally down
in fucking Anaheim. Um,
which I thought was pretty perfect for
him to be heading down towards Orange
County with whatever the fuck it is on
his head to talk to a bunch of people
that, you know, whatever the
fuck they did to their face.
You know, I swear to God, Hollywood
gets such, gets so much shit for like,
you know, like everybody out
here has plastic surgery.
I'm not saying they don't, but I'm
at least it's decent. Jesus Christ,
you go down to fucking Orange County
with all those real housewives and those
white Bruce Jenner looking
dudes. You know what I mean?
Remember Bruce was still Bruce, remember
when Caitlin was still Bruce and uh,
the dude had his eyes done, you
know, and the nose and all that.
They all had like those fucking, I
think at that bit about that my act,
they gavel have that Bruce Jenner eyes
and I used to, I thought it was bullshit.
I was, you know,
okay.
You know,
when my wife would watch
the real housewives of a
housewives of Orange County,
I'd be like, all right. They pick
the six biggest psycho couples.
They could find people down
here, don't look like this.
And then I went down to Irvine and I was
playing the Improv and I walked around
the mall and I was like, wait a minute,
wait a minute. These fucking people,
they, I don't know what
they're doing out here.
I think when you get into warmer client
climates and people who have to wear
less clothes, they really start
doing the plastic surgery shit.
You know what I mean? All you
guys in those winter climates,
you can in your puffy
coats, you know, sport coat,
buttoned down shirt. I'll
never forget that one.
I used to work in a warehouse when I
was a young lad. Full head of hair,
fucking abs, the whole thing.
Half as many freckles, you know,
sunny outlook on life. Oh,
it was a long time ago.
I remember once a year we'd have the
company picnic and all these fucking suits
who looked like they were in at least
halfway decent shape. They'd showed up.
They show up a tee shirts
and Holy Shit, Jesus Christ,
the fucking rolls just
fucking spilling up.
Pushing out the fucking
t-shirts. It was horrific.
I just remember looking
at these people going,
this guys weren't in
the company this time.
I'm taking orders from this tub of
shit. And they could feel it too.
They could feel it. Um,
they felt the eyes looking at them.
Shame. You could shame people.
Could fetch shame people back in
88 89. Not Anymore. Not Anymore.
Now I'm now I'm the problem. Right. It's
not their fucking 8,000 calories a day.
You know, it's what happened
to them when they was six.
That's why they're eating fucking ice
cream with candy bars in it. I'm sorry.
Anyways, let's plow ahead here. Yes.
So I have absolutely no idea what
the fuck is going on at anywhere,
at any time. Anything. All I know
is I'm in a fucking writers room.
Not Evidently meet me in St Louis.
Louie meet me at the fair.
Evidently my Saint Louis Blues loss
last night, you know, they came back,
they tied it up, four
games, two games to two.
And that's the last game I saw cause I've
been stuck in this fucking room and I
forgot to tape the last couple
of times. Um, you know, cause we,
you know,
we had one every once in a while you
just have a fucking a story and you're
trying to do it. Everybody's got 15,000
notes. You know, this isn't tracking,
it's not on the page. I don't think
we earned this. What's the motivation?
You've got to raise the stakes. And
for those of you not in the business,
that means you're not going to see
anybody you love for the next 48 hours.
So I missed everything. Evidently,
according to people on Twitter,
the sharks gave the blues,
the old right there,
Fred and game five and six
sit down and shut the fuck up.
My condolences to blues fans.
Um, I know you wanted more,
but a great season. You know,
you beat the fucking blues,
you beat the fucking stars and then
you lost the fucking sharks. All right.
And I believe it was meatloaf
who said two out of three. Sorry.
Um, yeah, that's fucking brutal, man.
Especially when you get that deep into
the playoffs and then it's just fucking
over. And then you just sit there
and like, now what do I do? Well,
you live in St Louis. This is what you do.
You go to a cardinals game and you watch
the rams pack up and leave your city,
and this is what you should do.
Rather than crying in your
fucking Peyton Manning,
partially owned beer, um,
what you should do is, uh,
you guys ought to fucking talk to the
Arizona cardinals, tell them to come back.
You know? I mean, that's what I would
do. Oh, what's your belt now? I wouldn't,
I wouldn't even know how to begin.
I wouldn't know how to begin to go
about doing something like that.
Okay.
Yeah. I mean, I would have no idea how to,
I have no idea how to go about anything.
I'm one of those fucking guys. You,
you should do. He should fucking
do this. So, yeah. How do you,
how do you do that? And I'm
like, I'm like Donald Trump,
except I'm not running
for president. You know,
build a fucking wall
between here and Mexico.
I'm gonna make Mexico pay for it. Oh
yeah. How are you gonna do that, Donald?
Ah, the fucking guy. Can you
fucking believe that, that, I mean,
it's fun. It's, it's
okay.
Ben and Hillary Clinton.
I cannot believe people are going to
fucking vote for either one of them.
I just cannot fucking believe
it on fucker believable.
They'll vote for Hillary Clinton.
They'll put her in fucking office
and then bitch, that nothing changed.
How many fucking times? Remember
that? [inaudible] we're gonna fucking,
we got a new guy. We got hope. It's
going to end the war. Close down.
Guantanamo Bay. It's nothing
fucking chair. Nothing JJ.
It's exact fucking SAPE dig. And
he got this fucking jerk off.
Who's just, all he just says is, no
matter what, you bring up a Donald,
what's up with your shirt? This is the
best shirt. I have the best shirts.
I'll have the best shirts
of any president ever.
And there's a fucking zillion people
losing their fucking minds going,
this guy, this guy's going
to turn it around. I guess.
He said the other day, he took a
physical, he's 69 years old and he said,
the doctor said he had the, I have, he
said, I had the, I have the best body,
the best body of any 69 year old he's
ever seen. Like how do you not see like,
you know what he's like, remember
that guy who wrote the twist Karma?
Let's do the twist, right? And
then next summary comes out, hey,
write another set song.
A twist again like we did last
summer. It's the same fucking song.
The guy actually brief
reference back. Like, you know,
do you remember when
I wrote the same song?
It was a year ago. Um, the
fuck was that guy's name.
I know it wasn't Charlie
Pride Chubby checker.
You know what's worse about anytime
you bring up Chubby Checker,
then somebody always has to tell you
the story of how he got his name. Well,
you know, there was fats, dominoes.
They said fat Chubby, domino checker.
Yes. Everybody started that story.
We all saw Dick Clark tell that story
and then everybody told it in the fucking
bars. You can't. Um, anyways, so.
Oh, I haven't given you
guys the update on my side.
Uh Oh. Oh, oh.
Um,
I think I found the cure for it.
Okay.
I have not sat down for more
than fucking, I don't know,
six seconds for the last like 48 hours
and it seems to be doing wonders for me.
That's the hardest thing about
having Sciatic, either one.
I drive to the fucking
office and come back. Um,
I basically stand up in the writer's
room and when I'm sick of standing I just
lay down on the floor like one of
those fucking animals at the airport.
Some of the pictures you guys are
sending me to a fucking hilarious.
This guy sent me one with
this guy was like, you know,
they have the row of chairs. He
was sleeping underneath them,
like perpendicular to
them. So he had his legs,
his ass and his lower back were
underneath the chair laying on his front.
And then he was like holding onto like
his hooded sweatshirt that he was using
as a pillow. He had that all wrapped
with his head on the side, like a,
like a little kids sleeping
with a stuffed animal.
Um,
I mean, gee, like how long is
your flight been delayed that you,
you just lost that much?
I don't know.
Respect for yourself that you can fuck
in late. I mean, it was kitten who,
I mean, I get on a plane every once in
a while. It's a long fucking flight.
You know, you might kick your
shoes off, you got your socks on,
you keep your socks on top of your shoes.
You might do something
like that for a minute,
provided your feet don't fucking stink.
Provided you took a shower that day.
You got on some fucking fairly new
socks in a fairly new pair of sneakers.
There's nothing wrong with that.
But Jesus Christ and he started walking
around the fucking plane going into the
bathroom animals. So anyways,
anyways, let me, let me, uh,
let me get back to the sports
here. So the blues are knocked out.
The sharks have made
their first final, um,
the cavs kicked the fuck out of the, the,
the raptors as far as I know. And
I've only, you know, like I said,
I just watch highlights of this shit
dumb as fucking move was the raptors to
start doing the a wagon. The finger.
Why would you do that? You know,
hey, we're finally starting
to win here. Why don't we, uh,
piss off the calves and
get them more motivated?
They only have Lebron
fucking James, you know, um,
and OKC is in the process
of uh, raping the A.
Okay.
The fuck are they the California seals
who they playing golden state warriors.
Um, [inaudible]
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
I've missed all of it and I don't
know anybody on any fucking team.
I mean other than the
stars, I know those guys.
So I'm going to shut up about it,
but I am tonight I'm going to tape game
seven of the pens lightening and I'm
also going to take the a,
the OKC game cause I want to see if
they're going to close out the warriors.
Um,
and then, you know, you know, it's funny,
all you need to do is just
watch highlights and you could,
you could still host a show. You know,
I got to tell you right
now, formal clip on the,
whoever makes the finals in the
east, let's say Cleveland Winds,
I'll tell you from of
Cleveland Cavaliers. Oh,
you gotta be concerned with the
[inaudible] of Oklahoma City.
Consider the [inaudible] Hey
Peter Warriors, you know,
to perennial favor taught the worst. Um,
okay,
that's amazing. The shit
that they're doing out there.
I wish I was watching it and I didn't,
so I'm going to shut up about it all
right before it's any more excruciating to
all you cons out there. Um, yeah,
so we're sitting there out right in
the fucking show and there's all these
Goddamn fucking,
okay.
Like storm troopers driving up and
down the street. You ever see those,
those fucking lunatics, cops like this,
the riot gear. Once you know that,
you'd think you'd only see them.
Okay.
You'd think you'd only see them in
like countries where they have like a
dictator.
You know where the truck is driving down
the street and they're standing on the
outside of it, holding onto
it like just, just way,
way over the top. Like what the fuck?
I thought I lived in a
democracy. What the fuck is that?
They were driving over to like Jimmy
Kimmel because Trump was going to go over
there and say that he was the
greatest panel guest ever. Um,
yeah,
and they're fucking driving
over. They're like lunatics.
One of the biggest bullshit things ever
is that in this country you're allowed
to protest. It's such bullshit.
You're not, you show up to protest,
you stand in there with your sign and
then the cops come down and they beat the
shit out of you. That's
basically what happens.
Or you file for a permit and they tell
you where you can protest and it's down
the street and, and up
over a fucking hill.
And if we even remotely raise your
voice, you get a Billy club to the face.
And that's pretty much every single
fucking country out there that considers
itself a democracy. Now, the ones
that have a fucking dictator,
you're not even allowed to do it.
They just come out and they shoot you.
So I guess, you know,
compared to getting shot,
okay,
it's fucking unbill I just
don't fucking get it. Why,
what is wrong with a bunch of
people chanting with signs?
I'm not talking about the people start
jumping on cop cars cause those are the
guys that they always show.
But even if you don't do that,
they just come down and they
beat the fuck out of you. Um,
yeah,
I'd hate to have that job as a cop.
It's gotta be so weird driving down
there going like, wait a minute.
These are fellow Americans,
they're protesting.
This is the sign of a healthy
democracy. And then you've got your guy,
why not tell you
yeah,
to slam the club on their fucking
head. You know, you're gonna ask me.
Ha. Um,
okay.
But they had like all these
fucking trucks and shit.
They would just fly and up and
down the fucking street, you know,
and then they'll put it on the news and
be eight people that will flipping the
fuck out and that's all
they're going to show.
And then the other thousand that showed
up and would just show to stand in there
and they're all going to get defined
by them. You know, it works well.
I guess I'm doing that to the cops. Right?
Defining them by all the ones
that beat the fuck out of them.
That's what I like to do.
People I'd like to make a point and
then I like to just completely fucking
destroy everything that I said. You know
what, this, this podcast just be, just,
just be called the, I have
no answers. I have arguments,
but I have no answers. Hey, have you guys
visited the all things comedy website,
atc.com. Have you been there
lately? While you should,
some of the greatest podcasts on
in the free world are on there.
And, um,
I'd appreciate if you'd swing by and
check it out every once in a while if you
could, if you get sick of this podcast,
this plenty of the podcast to listen to.
Um, let me do a little bit of fucking
reads here really quickly before I fucking
okay.
What do I get here? 1618 fucking
minutes. Sorry. I gotta get moving here.
All right, here we go. Zip
Recruiter. Oh, by the way,
I got to tell you this, I fucking,
I couldn't sleep last night, right?
So like four 50 in the
morning, I'm just, I'm gone.
I'm on Twitter and up for whatever
reason. I'm just fucking looking at shit.
And I put my phone on silence and I
turned all the volume down cause knee is
sleeping next to me and then there was a
video and I clicked on it and I thought
because everything was off that I could
just fucking watch it with the sound
down. You know, I was watching
all those things for people.
Somebody falls down and they
put it to a song, you know,
and there was somebody doing
like those fucking, you know,
a burnout spinning around and shit
and fucking slammed into this guy.
So I wanted to hear what song they
put it too. I ain't want to see that.
I just wanted the screen to be
bigger so I could fucking see it.
And I press play and it came on full blast
and my wife just goes, Jesus
Christ. But what the fuck?
I flipped out and I was
like, sorry, sorry, sorry.
And then she immediately went back to
sleep and then for another half hour,
you know, I'm still on the
phone cause I can't sleep.
And then I hit another one,
like an asshole wasn't thinking,
I just wanted to see what
happened to this person.
And she fucking sat up and she
literally did the Ralph Kramden,
she just goes out, ah,
pointed at the fucking door.
And I wanted to start laughing, but I
knew she was going to get mad at me.
And then she just went back
to sleep and I didn't leave.
But I'm waiting for her to wake up
so I can tell her that she did that.
Depending on how tired she is, you
know, cause she might be pissed at me,
might still be pissed
at me. You know what?
That's one of those later in the day,
once at the end of the day when she can
go to sleep, I'll fucking bring it up.
All right, here we go. Oh look
everybody. It's a roll. Friends, zip
recruiter. Are you,
do you know where to post your
job to find the best candidates?
Posting your job in one place isn't
enough to find quality candidates today.
Do you want to find the perfect hire?
You need to post your job on all
the top job sites and now you can,
um, with zip
but crowded.com you can post
your jobs to 100 plus job sites,
including social media networks
like Facebook and Twitter,
all with a single click. You Lazy Prick.
Find candidates in any city
or industry nationwide.
Just post once and watch your
qualified candidates roll into zip
crude is easy to use. Interface, I don't
know what an interface is. I've said,
that's one of those fucking computer
words. Interface. No juggling.
He punched her interface. No juggling
emails or calls to your office.
Quickly screen candidates, rate
them and hire the right person fast.
Find out today why zip,
but Croda has been used by over a
hundred thousand businesses and right now
listeners can try Z,
but grata for free by going to z
recruiter.com/bird that zip
[inaudible] dot com slash bro Hey,
ziprecruiter.com/barb all
right hallux. He looks,
what is it about buying a mattress
that leaves you feeling violated?
Why would you bring up
mattress and violated?
Why would you say that in the
same sentence? Jesus Christ.
What is it about it? I Dunno.
You wore loose jeans and bent over
to see how much the mattress cost.
I have no idea. Let's read more copy and
find out. Is it the pushy salespeople?
Okay, we've got mattress violated.
Now this person's being pushy. Ah,
the fake presidents' Day sale
or the fact that you, you know,
you'll regret what you bought as you do
the walk of shame out of the mattress
store. Walk a shame like you
fucking bank somebody right now.
You're wondering why
a those days are over.
It's thanks to Helux sleep where you can
buy a mattress online customized view
for hundreds of dollars instead
of thousand go to helix,
sleep.com answer a few simple
questions and Helen's creates you cuss,
creates your custom sleep profile
to build you your perfect mattress.
The result pitcher ask,
evidently their customers report a 30%
improvement in overall sleep quality.
Okay?
Your mattress will arrive at your door
in about a week and shipping is 100%
free. You have 100 nights to try
it out, do what you want on it,
and if you don't love it,
they'll pick it up for free with
rubber gloves and give you 100% refund,
no questions asked. It's
like it never happened.
That's copy is so fucking creepy. You can
do whatever you want on this mattress.
Soil it for a hundred nights. We'll
show up. We're not asking any questions.
We don't want to know what
happens and then what do they do?
Do they recycle it in a third
world like an old cell phone. Um,
if you do love your Hellickson
mattress, keep it and your dignity.
That's why everyone from GQ magazine
to Forbes are all talking about helix
sleep. Go to helic, sleep.com/birth
and get $50 off your order.
That's helix sleep.com/bar
hey helic sleep.com/bird.
That's h. E. L. I. X. All right.
How many more of these fucking
things I got here? All right, uh,
the next one. Score big. All right.
You're paying too much for tickets
between all the markups and last minute
convenient charges, even print and
home fees. Are you fucking kidding me?
Over here, you end up paying court
side prices for nosebleed seats.
Score big is here to change that.
Did you know that 40% of all
live event tickets go on sold?
And did you know there's a place
to get these seats at huge savings?
It's called ScoreBig.
Well then you bought them.
How did you get them to the fucking
team? Just gave them to you.
I really don't understand what that means.
Score bid works directly with your
favorite teams. Ah, that's how it works.
And artists to get their unsold seats
at unpublished prices only with score.
So that's when you know you're
fucking not selling any tickets.
When score big goes, hey, you want me
to take half the arena off your hands?
You non-selling cunt.
I'm only with score big.
Can you name a ticket price
and be guaranteed to payable
a below box office up
to 60% off. Here's what you do. Well,
what do you do to your s did you buy up
all the tickets Ashley Simpson didn't
sell? I mean, is this going to be shit?
People want to see one
go to score a big deal.
I don't think Bruce
Springsteen Su score big once.
Go to s one go to score big.com
or download the new score.
Big app for your iPhone and
find the event in seats.
You want to make an offer with score,
Biggs name a ticket price feature. Three,
get an instant answer and save
up to 60% on your tickets.
I got a question. If you fucking buying
up 40% of the tickets, go on salt.
There's no way that happens
that Bruce Springsteen, Beyonce,
all those huge acts. So
do you not sell those?
Who Do you sell it for?
The a insync review union
reunion. Yeah, in synchrony.
Union sands, fucking Justin Timberlake.
It's all the original people
except the one that hit big. Um,
never any fees and
shipping is always free.
You can count on unbeatable
prices and great seats.
And when you're in great seats, you can
actually enjoy the game or the show.
All the more. Next time
you see any game or show,
go to score big first
and see how you can save,
how much you can save for the
easiest way to save on tickets.
Download the new score. Big app
for your iPhone. Like I said,
fucking 10 minutes ago,
enter Promo Code Birch,
check the checkout and you'll save
$20 off your first price. No iPhone,
no problem. Get $20 off online
to@scorebig.com that's scorebig.com
promo code bur. Um, hey, why not?
Why not right? Can All
be, what's that other one?
Everybody always goes to stubhub. Right?
It's good that there'll be another person
out there. Scalpel and tickets. Right.
Alright. Club Debbie
clipped. Gib hit my daddy.
Would you love me more than Jian
delivers wine straight to your door.
We send you wine that is personalized
to your own Palette tastes.
Uh, through our Palette quiz,
our recommendations become even more
personalized with every bottle you rate.
We work with top wine makers and growers
from around the world directly make our
, to make our all of our own wine.
Our $13 bottles would normally retail
for 20 bucks plus a more than $20,
I think is what they were
trying to say. They're a,
you choose the type and quantity of
the bottles with no membership fee or
cancellation fee. 100%
satisfaction guarantee. Creative.
We partner with local artists to develop
wine labels that are unique works of
art right now at club. Debbie, did
I tell you I can speak Spanish?
Is offering listening listeners $20 off
your first order when you go to club
Debbie, I wouldn't build a
wall.com/bar and it gets even better.
I know you all hate paying for shipping.
So club Debbie, I used to go to Yale,
will actually pay for your shipping
on orders of four bottles or more.
So take something off your to do
list. Just go to club, Debbie.
I never went to class.com/ [inaudible]
to get $20 off your first order.
Now that's club Debbie and weapons of
mass destruction.com/burn. All right,
that's it. And we're out. We're out. Um,
anyways, what the fuck can I finish on?
I really don't have anything
to finish on other than um,
am excited that we're doing the table.
Refer a number five next
week we write all week.
We don't have a table read and then
three weeks in a row we do episodes six,
seven, eight week of just
writing, no table read.
And then nine 10,
and then I'm fucking done in the writer's
room and maybe my fucking ass over
here can fucking stop sending
electric jolts down my fucking leg
laying down in the room. Now Guy,
I feel like fucking like some
Howard Hughes without the money.
This fucking wolf man nails. You know,
I saw somebody the other day when I was
in the airport and they were playing
classical guitar. You know what
I mean? And it sounded beautiful.
But the only thing that sucks
about playing classical guitars,
you got to grow your nails
like a fucking wolf man.
You know we're on one of your hands and
it's all good when you're sitting down
playing guitar. But the second you
put your guitar down, you just,
it looks fucking gross.
I'm out of my mind.
And I guess that's no reason to stop.
There's a few instruments you always
have to pay the price for like trumpet
trumpets, one of them, you know?
Okay.
You start playing the trumpet. You get
that fucking Callus on you, on your,
on your lip. You know, it's one
of my favorite instruments ever.
I love the fucking trumpet,
but I would never play it,
play it because I W I wasn't
willing to pay the price.
And plus I knew I would only be okay
at it. Who wants to be okay with it?
Fucking trumpet. Callous.
I'm not this guy.
I'll tell you that right
now. Alright, now here we go.
I'm going to give you my
predictions for all the games,
sixes and sevens out there. And a,
you can take all of these predictions
to the bank and they won't give you shit
for them cause I haven't
watched any of these series. Um,
the goal of the, of the
Golden State Warriors will
when,
yeah,
the next thing I Willie, I
dunno, I didn't see the game.
All I know is everybody said the
exact same thing. I'll tell you,
this team is a lot longer and a lot
more towel to the near used to sing.
Everybody did a version of that.
I guess they're long and
they're talented and uh,
the warriors haven't seen anything like
this even though they played Oklahoma
during the regular season, but I don't
think they were looking at them. Um,
all right. The uh,
Tampa Bay lightning will
win game seven tonight.
Alright. So I feel like I'm o for two
already. And what else? We got the calves.
Oh, the calves that went in, the next
one, that fucking series is over.
You don't fucking wag your finger and
fucking Lebron James face or any of his
teammates or Yeti your
fucking mind. You know,
all these fucking actors
running around, bulking up,
putting on their fucking underoos,
playing these superheroes, right?
And all these fucking nerds
going down to fucking check, uh,
who could fucking be when the hulk or
captain America. And what about Thor will,
he's got, he's stupid. He just
says a hat and a hammer, you know,
you cut his hair, his fucking hammer
breaks all his fucking bullshit, you know,
and then you got these fucking comic
con [inaudible] who actually dress like
superheroes for real and walk
around and try and stop crime.
You know what I mean? Cause they just
so want these superheroes to be real.
Whoa. Just go to a cavs game. You
stupid cunt and watch Lebron James.
Okay. Lebron James could grab Batman
and Robin in one fucking hand.
Throw him through a plate glass window
and he'd still get the end one if someone
was hanging off his
other fucking arm, okay.
Just go buy a ticket and sit
down like a fucking gentlemen.
Stop standing in line
with fucking 50 people.
Dress like Chewbacca and an
and aqua man down in San Diego.
Whatever the fuck you go. Cause he can
sit down and talk to the cast of, uh,
I don't fucking one of those
goddamn shows. What does, what does,
what does that, what does a car? I
guess mine's a comic con show. Huh?
Now that I think about it. Jesus.
I hope they don't play that audio.
If we ever do that show, well maybe
they do. What are they going to do? Wow.
Throw some of their rough action
figures still in the box at me.
You know why it's worth more
if it's still in the box. A,
I can't say why I can't say, ah,
you know why it's fucking Weirdos.
Cause you know it hasn't been anywhere
disgusting. I'm happy red nose day.
What is this here? A people send me
this. Twitter is for kids. You red nose.
Fuck. Oh, somebody just told me what
the red nose thing is for. It goes,
it's for kids. Oh, is that what it's
for? It's for kids. All that explains it.
Yeah.
I don't know why I'm such a
Douche, but I fucking cannot stand.
I can't fucking stand when a bunch of
celebrities get behind a fucking cause and
there's a fucking ribbon or
a God damn nose and they,
I don't know why. I just, it drys.
I know it's a good cause behind the cars,
but I fucking hate it.
And then everybody's got to find their
own unique way to have the nose on their
face. How they're going to
fucking hold it. It's just, Ah,
it just drives me up the fucking wall
that in famous people telling me who to
vote for. Oh, you know what?
I didn't know who to vote for.
And then you told me. I mean,
I guess I bitch about it,
but I'm not telling you who to vote
for. I don't fucking know, like,
make a fucking 20 minute video. Here's
why you should vote for fucking Freddy.
Fuckface you know, we're
running out of water. Oh,
shut up. Um,
you know what's funny
about what I just said?
I could literally just stare in a mirror
and say that to myself in a lot of
ways. Right. I never tell
you constitute a vote for.
I just make fun of the people you do
vote forth. That's what I do. Hey,
you want some comb over orange haired
cunt? Why don't you just vote for me
instead of Donald Trump?
The fuck is wrong with you.
I have the greatest podcast ever.
Yeah.
Nobody tells us shit joke like me.
This club owner told me after
in 40 years of running a club,
he's never seen shit jokes.
Like my shit jokes I'm speaking of which
I'm actually doing a bad fall for the
fuck you want to vote for. I don't give
a fuck. It's not gonna change anything.
We're a bunch of animals and we're doomed
to destroy each other. So, you know,
get yourself a dog and a hobby.
You know, find somebody you like,
treat them nice and a, that'd be great.
They'll stay with you and when
the whole thing goes down,
you'll have someone to
hug Jesus. Um, anyways,
that, that, that made me lose my
complete train of thought. Oh,
tonight to not tonight. Tonight.
Whoa. Um, what was Phil Colin's
thinking in the 80s? Jesus Christ.
He's such a great musician of the
worst fucking songs. After, after a
[inaudible], um, then all
of a sudden he was doing,
you can't hurry love after. You
can't hurry love. Then did that song
easy lover was decent.
Yeah.
And then it just went
off the fucking rails.
Yeah,
it's a studio. Yeah. That
one we'll use yelling at you,
you know,
telling us to think twice because it's
another day for you and me in paradise.
You know, when you see a homeless person,
it's like, hey, fuck head. You know,
the way I'm living compared
to the way you're living.
You don't need to look at a
homeless guy. Just look at me.
She feel lucky when you look at me.
You don't have to go all the way down to
that level. Do you? You fucking castle.
Um, tonight I'm going to be
down at the comedy still, uh,
doing a benefit for
kids. That's another one,
but I won't be wearing a red nose. Uh,
but I will be jumping around
like a fucking clown. This
is for a, you know what?
I don't know what it's for. It's for
sick kids in hospitals. I have no idea.
All I know is whoever put
it together. Um, I dunno.
I trust him. Steve Simone. I trust
the guy. So I figured, you know,
I figured it's on the up and
up. Who knows? I don't fucking,
I don't pretend to know things. Um, hey,
is anybody out there who listens to this?
Are you one of those fucking riot police
guys that rides on the outside of the
truck? And when you do it as much
as your adrenaline is going up,
do you ever just think of
how fucking ridiculous it is?
Yeah.
You know, like what are we doing here?
We got to get over to Jimmy Kimmel.
Donald Trump is there, um,
what's going to happen?
Uh, all right. I think, I think I
pissed off enough people with this one.
All right, good. Um, I have a great
weekend you cunts and I will talk to you
on Monday. And like I said, you can take
all of those predictions to the bank.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
hey, what's going on? It's Bill Barr.
Yeah. Isn't that exciting? It's the, uh,
it's the Monday morning
podcast. How are you?
Thanks for coming to my page and thank
you for listening and thank to is
Memorial Day. So here
we go. Something Nice.
Thank you to all the men and women who
are serving this country right now,
sweating their asses off
over there in Iraq. Uh,
I don't know what you supposed to say
today. Do you say Happy Memorial Day?
I don't think you do. That
doesn't seem a fitting.
I Dunno what I'm trying to see if there's
a memorial day parade out here in La
and if, if so, where would
it be? You know what I mean?
And the Memorial Day parade is a very, uh,
to serious things.
So I can't picture the parade going
down sunset honoring the fallen men and
women who have served this country as
the parade goes by the fucking saddle
ranch. You know,
there's two whores watching some
shit head, right? A fake horse,
you know what I mean? I just don't
know where they would have it out here.
I'm really not up on the parades out
here in la since I moved out here.
I know they had the gay pride parade.
I know that's an Halloween. Um,
that one's always hilarious and confusing.
I've never understood the
gay pride parade. You know,
they spend fucking 51 weeks out
of the year trying to be like,
look, we're normal. We're
just born this way. Okay.
For the love of God. Stop tying US
defense posts in Wyoming. All right,
we're not against God. We're just wired
this way. You know, and then they,
they have the gay pride parade and
you'd think they'd come down the street,
you know, try and look a
little bit respectable.
And what happens is everybody's coming
down the street with a Dick in their
hand. They got fucking, I
just don't get it. You know,
it's just the Goddamn free for all.
So fucking spectacle. I
definitely recommend seeing
it if you ever want to just,
uh,
if you ever wanted to see
what 300 would look like if a,
that's what it looks like.
It looks like that movie 300 wood
dildos cause everybody's shredded.
I don't know what gay,
why hasn't a gay guy put out
like a fucking exercise video?
You know what I mean?
It's always easy. These,
he's half a fat guys who
actually heterosexual and
now we standing on a beach,
nobody is more shredded dead
than those, those gay dudes.
I don't know what it is. Cause there
are their weights and those Dildos,
is that what it is?
Dod a fucking balloon to the wall
and you do pull ups or something. Oh,
speaking of that shit, I know a few
weeks ago I was talking about, you know,
wanting to get in shape
and uh, I actually, I, I,
you know some about that t 90 x system
and a couple people said it was bullshit
ever. The people said that they liked
it all. I know it was like, you know,
200 bucks in like 58 DVDs.
I was like a time life series, you
know, on how to get abs or something.
And it was just a, it was
too overwhelming. And I
go on the road too much.
So I found the solution. I, uh,
went online and I bought some, uh,
I bought rings, you know,
those rings, uh, Jim misuse.
I'm going to put up a channel bar today
and I swear to God by the end of the
year, I'm going to learn how to
do a fucking iron cross. And, uh,
I just watched that
gymnastic shit and I missed,
nobody is more shredded than those dudes.
And there's something I like about
being able to lift your own body weight.
You know what I mean? That we, you know,
if you can like climb
up a fucking building,
I think that's way better than
being able to bench press a car.
Maybe it depends on the situation
that you're in. You know,
some fat fucks sitting on your chest
going, what are you going to do? Well,
what are you gonna do about it?
We're do, we're gonna do like,
I guess then if you could bench 400
pounds, that would be like a good thing.
But, uh, I don't know. House fire,
you being chased by somebody if you can
go up the fucking building like spider
man. I think that, I
think that that's, uh,
I have to think that that's always better.
That'd be a cool thing. Jesus Christ.
I can't get it out, Bill. I'm like, I
think, I think I did. They did that,
that you said you said you
wanted one spider. Um, yeah.
So see if I can get you the
website here. This is what this is.
This is what this podcast is becoming
is becoming me informing you on the
fucking whacked out shit
that I do. All right.
This is the training rings is where I
went to and the www.training rings.com and
a is check it out man. I want to be
able to do one of those muscle ups,
you know,
and I'm gonna start wearing really tight
tee shirts on a on stage and then I'll
be ready for the gay pride parade.
Look at that. I brought it full circle.
All right. All right. Before
I get into the podcast,
those of you who are new to my podcast,
I basically had to do one of these every
week and uh, people send me advice.
Sometimes people ask for me,
advice. People send me questions,
I try to ask for them, answer
them. I mean best of my ability.
Um, I dunno and you know, I don't read,
I just sorta start talking.
So don't really listen to me.
Just I hope I make you laugh at some
shit and I hype upcoming shit that I have
like this week. Um, May 24th,
I have a real busy week this
week, May 24th, um, the next,
um, installment of the uninformed show
with bill and Joe de Rosa, my radio show,
our radio show,
me and Joe that we do on XM two o two
is going to be this Saturday night,
May 24th, uh,
on XM two o two from
9:00 PM to 12 midnight.
Uh, I'm going to be a Caroline's
comedy club this week,
but it's going to be weird.
I'm going to be there Thursday,
not on Friday, Saturday and Sunday.
Why aren't you gonna be there
on, on Friday, Bill? Um,
because I have to fly back to la because
I'm doing stand up on an awards show.
Oh my God. Are you going to be
doing stand up at the Oscars?
Now I'm going to be doing
stand up at the, uh,
Spike TV awards show. I don't know.
I never heard of it either. But,
uh, Mexico, I dunno. I'm excited.
I never got to do an award show. So, uh,
I'll let you guys know
when and when that, uh,
when that's going to be and a usual
that that part of the podcast sucks.
Whenever I hide what I have
coming up, I don't know.
The whole thing starts to
grind to a halt. I Dunno.
And then I never have half the fucking
information. It's ridiculous. So, uh,
alright, before I get into my, my
rent for the week, um, I actually,
because it is memorial day and I used
to got a really cool email from somebody
who's over there. I don't know if
they're in the army or the marines.
I'm assuming it's one of those
two branches cause they're, uh,
they appear to be on the ground
over there. Um, it says, uh,
I hope to get back to the states that
come to see you sometime. A quick story.
And it was on a mission the other day and
I picked up the radio and called to my
lead truck and said, is
that tactile in your egg?
The other tactical commanders
said, it's asparagus.
It was a little bit of humor for us.
Good stuff. Talk to you later bill.
How fucking cool is that? Huh?
Somebody sucking over there and Falucia
sweeping out the houses or whatever
the hell you do. You know to what?
A couple of my jokes. I was
one of the coolest emails.
They have a god and a actually have
the name of the guy who sent me that.
So when you, when you get back safe,
I'm going to hook you up at a show.
All the rest of you
comes listening to this.
Don't start sending me emails pretending
that you're over there just so I can
give you a couple of free tickets next
time I play slap e's and fucking Omaha,
Nebraska. All right, that's bad
Karma. That's bad fucking Karma.
All right. All right.
Here's my fucking rant for the week or
right people and I'm going to try to
remain calm throughout this without
losing my shit because I think it's a very
important thing that a lot
of people are dealing with.
And I'd much rather try to
get the information out and
Amy's in a nice calm way.
That way my message will be heard and
I won't and I won't seem like a psycho.
All right.
Forget about the fact that I talked to
myself for half an hour if we become
these fucking texts. Okay.
So last week I was flying to
New York to do the HBO show,
a down and dirty with Jim Norton.
I was very excited to do it.
Anytime you get to do HBO as a
comedian is a big thing, a big,
big thing. You know, I was psyched to
see Jim, Jim's the first guy from my,
a graduating class of comedians to get
a high profile standup Gig like that.
So it was really cool. You know, I was
anticipating seeing him hosting the show.
Okay,
Yada, Yada, Yada. All that stuff. Okay.
I get a first class round trip tickets.
Fucking lax. No, don't swear. Don't
swear bill. Keep it nice. I, hi.
A first round. First class
round trip tickets. Okay.
Counting to 10 here from
lax to Newark. Okay.
I don't know if you guys
have flown first class.
I do it every once in a while
when I get get a fucking TV show.
I don't do it on a regular basis because
I did that for one month and I got an
$8,000 credit card bill
and I said, you know what?
I don't think coaches that bad.
So now I got a free round
trip. First Class ticket.
Did I make that point yet? I think I
did. So before I get off the plane,
I haven't eaten but I'm
thinking that doesn't matter.
I have a first class round tickets.
I am going to be wined and dined
from lax all the way to Newark,
New Jersey. I'm going to
have fucking wine and dine.
That's what I'm going to have.
Probably get a foot massage, you know,
little hot towel, maybe a quick
little, how are you doing? You know,
first class and we sit there and look
down on the people as they're getting into
the back of the plane back. Like I'm
running some big successful business,
you know, so I get on the plane,
I'm starving. Oh boy. Oh boy,
I'm going to get something to
eat. Yeah, they hand me the menu.
Okay. And what is, I got two choices. I
can either get an omelet with potatoes,
some fruit.
Okay.
I like the muffin and some
orange juice or cereal
and I'm like wow, that's
sort of a limited menu.
Who the fuck would get cereal?
Go Gone with the, I'm like,
who the fuck wouldn't
get it on but a Vegan.
All right, you got me. But most, you know,
generally speaking everybody's
going to get the x.
So I go and I read the final line of
the menu and in parentheses it says,
please accept our apologies if
your selection is not available.
And I was like,
what the fuck is about to happen here?
Okay.
What do you mean please
accept our apologies if your
selection is not available.
This is first fucking class. Alright,
that shit happens back in coach,
when you sit in row 38 f you
know that may run out of eggs.
They run out of eggs in the back where
they got people's fucking stacked up like
cordwood. You know? Is that even
a word? A court quarter wood,
isn't it an amount of
wood? I don't fucking know.
That's a question for you guys.
What is it? Is that a quarter wood?
I cleared land one day and I heard that,
that expression and I just used
it and I know what the fuck it is.
They got people jam packed in the
back of the God damn airplane.
That's where you run out of x. You don't
run out of fucking eggs in first class.
See, I'm flipping out. Take it down bill.
Make sure your message is heard. Okay,
so I'm sitting there. They start
at the front of first class.
There's like five rows.
I'm in row four I'm doing the math and
they're going through and you know what?
Nobody's picking the
cereal. Of course the knock.
Why would you pick cereal when
you can get an Omelet? All right.
Needless to say, they get
to my row and they say,
what would you like Miss Tuber? And
I said, I would like the Omelet, sir.
And they say, Ooh, I'm sorry. Um,
we're out of eggs. And I go, what
do you mean you're outta eggs?
A yeah. Um, everybody ordered
eggs and EDA, we're out of eggs.
And I go, what do you have left
knowing full well what they had left.
And he goes, uh, we
have cereal and a Bagel.
And I looked at the guy and I said, dude,
I paid for a first class
ticket, which I didn't,
of course I didn't have got it for free,
but I don't give a fuck or I
don't want to make a point here.
I got to go for big air. I said,
I paid for first class ticket,
I'm not eating cereal. And the
guy was like, I know, I know. Um,
I know you're right. We don't think it's
right, but this is just how they do it.
And I'm like, what do you mean
this is how you do it? I go,
there's like 12 people here at
first-class. How do you run out of eggs?
This is first class. I'm not eating
cereal. The guy goes well on,
on odd flights.
We start at the front of first class
and on evens we start at the back row of
first class. It's like, dude,
it's fucking first class.
This shouldn't be a problem. I
want fucking x. And he's like,
I didn't say fucking, I go, I want x.
Okay.
And he's like, well, all we have is
serial. I'm sorry sir. And I just said,
you know what? I don't want anything,
right? Just start at piling.
So I'm sitting there fuming, the stomach
is growling. I got a six hour flight.
I'm starving to death in the widest
Goddamn airplane seat I've ever sat in my
life. So like two minutes
goes by and I swear to God,
the fucking flight attendant
comes back and he goes, um, a,
I just talked to the pilot, the
captain of the airplane, and he said,
he already ate so you can have
his eggs. And I was like, what?
He goes, the pilots said you
can have his X. I'm like,
I don't want his fucking eggs.
I don't want his fucking X.
I want my ex this as far as class.
This should be enough fucking x for me.
All right. And the God, he's
a pilot. He should get eggs,
fucking pancakes and waffles, whatever
the fuck he wants. I don't want that.
I don't want my pilot up
front fucking start, you know,
passing out all like edit and shit
cause he didn't get any
fucking eggs is ridiculous man.
I mean how much fucking money do you
have to mix? This is American Airlines,
by the way. This is American Airlines.
This is how fucking tight they are and
they're trying to blame it on these
fucking fuel prices. Oh by the way,
I ended up taking the eggs because I was
so goddamn hungry and then I felt bad.
I'm sitting there reading,
I'm feeling guilty like I'm eating the
pilot's eggs and then another side I'm
feeling like a sell out cause I'm thinking
like maybe they're thinking they're
going to give me these eggs and I'm
not going to fucking fire off a goddamn
letter on their website, which I did.
It's fucking unreal.
American Airlines are.
I did the biggest fucking cuts
of an airplane ever an airline.
Do you remember what I, I remixed this
song a few weeks ago. Remember that
for those of you who didn't,
that was my new thing,
cause I'm sick of these
goddamn corporations and
they're fucking, they're happy.
Jingles. Is this scrolling you
over every single day still?
I read mix this song. They don't
win a little something like that.
We're at kid, Eh, fuck you.
You Izzy. Yes. I did that as a joke
two weeks ago and I swear to God, I've
never been more right in my life either.
The next day I get off
the Goddamn plane bitch.
Then I find out they're going to charge
$15 for your first carry on that you
first started the first bag that you
check and they keep blaming it on fuel
prices.
How the price of fuel keeps going up
and I'm telling you right now as the
passenger, if you believe that shit,
I don't know what to tell you. They
make money off of misery. Okay?
Nine 11 they made money. Okay.
I'm sure is their expenses go
up 20% whatever. But you know,
they don't just raise a 20 they raise a
25 and that's the same thing with this
fucking fuel. This is my question.
All right, who's going to start it? Okay.
I'm not starting it, but I swear to
God, if anybody out there starts it,
I'm going to follow. Okay.
There has to be some sort of fucking push
back because I don't know what's going
on with these, these fucking, he's got
the incorporations that it used to be.
The customer's always right and somehow
my lifetime, it's going to, you know,
fuck you and your mother customer.
That's their vibe. You know,
when I went to fly back my round
trip, first class ticket, I show up,
my fucking flight is canceled.
And rather than flying first
class nonstop from Newark to lax,
I was now flying coach to Dallas and
then first-class from Dallas to lax and,
and there was no voucher. They're like,
yeah, we're not offering anything.
It's like six months ago I would've got
a blow job if you fucked me this bed.
And she's just like, Nah, Nah.
Then they're not offering anything.
You've got to call the one 800 number.
And then I called the one 800 number.
They're like, no, you have to talk
to the person that deck. I'm like,
can't I just talk to
the person at the desk?
And then they hung up cause I said cunt.
So then I had to call back and then
the end of it all they gave me was 150
bucks. Portugal by like one
third of a coach ticket. Well,
once again, I won't get any fucking eggs.
So all I'm asking is who's going to start
it? Who's going to start the fucking,
you know what we need?
We need like a fucking a,
what's Charles Bronson's name and
those death wish movies, Paul Kurzy.
We need a fucking the
airline version of that.
Jesus Christ. I mean,
who the fuck wants to pay $15 for
their first bag that they check?
Everybody knows that's
bullshit. Nobody wants to do it,
but we're all going to do it
because we're all just by ourselves.
Twisting in the wind. Okay? But
we all showed up the first day,
June 15th so that promotion,
whatever the fuck it is,
and you show up at the airport with angry
faces and torches like we're going to
go try to get Frankenstein guarantee and
none of us has to pay 15 bucks. Okay?
I'm not trying to sign a Ryan here.
I'm just saying somebody start
passing out the two by fours.
I'm done with it. All right?
I'm not going to lead it
because I procrastinate and
everybody knows, you know,
they always chop off the
head so the body falls. Okay?
If I learned anything from the
1960s black, white male seam,
you fuck with the deal?
You have a convertible ride
in your future. All right?
But some good things do happen. So fuck,
I'm so pissed right now. If fucking
believe that the pilots eggs,
thankfully the piloted, can
you fucking believe that
30 years ago. But God damn
stewardesses, they didn't. It was,
first of all, they were all
hot. That's the one thing, okay?
It was the God damn
glamorous job. All right?
He had a one in 10 chance of hooking
up with one of the hottie stewards as
that's why people used to wear
suits. You want to look good.
It was like a nightclub. Everyone
was boozing, people were smoking.
You having a Goddamn party and the
fucking sky. Here's the one for you.
You know what first-class used to be.
This is the greatest story I've
ever heard as far as the FirstClass.
This is what it used to be as compared
to my fucking wear out of eggs.
First Class experience. Pan-Am
Airlines. I'm dating myself here.
All right. Pan-Am when used to fly to, uh,
I think it was John F. Kennedy airport.
I read about this shit on the Internet,
right? So it's gotta be
true. Um, first of all,
the metlife building that's right above
grand central station used to be the
Pantheon building. So when you used
to fly first class to JFK airport,
you got off first class and you,
you didn't go to a fucking town car and
sit and goddamn traffic on the lie or
wherever the fuck you go to the midtown
tunnel and take an hour and a half,
which ruins the first class experience.
You got off the fucking
plane at JFK airport.
They put you on a
helicopter, swear to God.
They put you on a helicopter and they
flew you to the top of the Pan Am
building. You've got off drinks.
We're waiting probably more broads with
those scarves tied around their necks.
Like fucking Dick Cabin. You get
another blow job. Then you took the,
took fucking elevated down to
the first floor, jumped in a cab,
you went to your hotel pre herpes
pre-AIDS here's some kind of splits.
Have a good fucking time. All
right? That was first class.
Back then something happened
where the, the wind,
something happened with a wind tipped
over a helicopter and the blades went
flying down to the street and
chop somebody in half. Okay,
but that's beside the point. I
really did happen by the way,
I forget who had shopped in half,
but he was a son of somebody.
Somebody obscurely famous, you know,
like the guy who invented like the
bookmarker or something. All right.
Jesus Christ. Some fucking winded after
that story. Um, which brings me to my,
uh, first bit of advice that
somebody gave me this week. Um,
bill taking naps can really help me out
when I get too negative and agitated.
But this can be hard for
you since you fly so much.
Running and lifting weights
also helps me out too. Well,
thank you for that
advice. Uh, I don't know.
I think the running and lifting weights
would help me out as you can tell with
my rage issues. But uh, taking naps,
I, I can't do it. Like, uh, I dunno.
My brain wakes me up. I don't
know how to shut it off.
So if anybody out there knows how
I can shut this fucking thing off.
All right. I'm really worked up here.
All right, here's a, here's some advice.
Somebody, this is how,
this is a question I get like every week
people will always give me this when
they safety people say I'm funny,
how do I become a comedian? Um,
I must get asked this like 10
times a week. This is what you do.
Fight five minutes of Shit
that you think is funny.
Sign up for an open mic when
they call your name. Go up there.
Hang on for dear life. Spit out as
much of it as you can. Remember,
tape the set, go home, listen
to it. Keep the jokes at work.
Got,
get rid of the ones that didn't and then
write some more jokes to take place.
Take the place of the ones that didn't
work and then you sign up for another
open mic. You repeat the process
and you just keep doing that.
And then eventually you build an act and
next thing you know you're a community
flying first class to a dream TV
gig without any fucking eggs. Oh No,
you get eggs, but we're going
to give you the guilt trip.
You can have the pilot's egg. They'll
just sit up there and be hungry.
What the fuck? All right.
It's podcasts I'm sensing is
getting a little long here.
Let me get onto the questions and I'll
get out of here and you guys can get on
with your memorial days. Okay, Bill,
question of a one you've always
seen dimension sports in your act.
I was wondering if you were involved
in any fantasy sports leagues. No,
I am not fantasy sports
leagues and gates. I fucking,
I can't stand them. They have
ruined sports. Talk in a bar.
People are aren't like affiliated
with fucking teams anymore. You Bring,
oh my God. You see the viking
swollen. They gave me CBCT. Really?
Really? What else do you have on your
fantasy? Came. Huh? A girlfriend.
Somebody who satisfies you sexually.
Uh, what else do you have a dream job?
We not fucking walled in by a cubicle. No,
I don't play fantasy sports
leagues. Actually know what,
I don't really know much about them. I
find that sports takes up, they take,
it picks up too much of my time
anyways, so I don't watch pregame.
I'm not in fantasy sports
leagues. I don't watch post-games.
I don't listen to any of those fucking
ranting raving lunatics that ESPN has
now. Anybody on ESPN for some
reason listens to these things.
Why is every show become two
people screaming at each other?
And why do you guys hype things up to
such a ridiculous fucking level that it
never, you know what I mean?
Like I remember the Patriots
was six and now they're like,
it's just the greatest team ever. Yeah,
yeah. I guess they are. I mean,
let's completely ignore the fact that the
cults were 13 and o two years earlier.
Let's, let's declare them the Glitz,
ask if they're the greatest team ever
when they're still fucking 20 games left
in the season. You dumb cons.
All right. Um, number two, uh,
Bill,
which end of your comedy crowds spectrum
do you prefer to put up with the
douchebag Frat guys who drank so much?
They decided to try and heckle you after
your show while you're signing cds.
Oh yeah. I know who this is that
happened to me in Chicago. Okay. Um,
or the older men who came to the show
with their wives that are afraid to laugh
at your jokes cause they want
to get laid that night. Um,
I definitely prefer that the older guys
who don't laugh cause he wanted to get
laid by their wife that night.
Um, because if I pick up on it,
it usually ends up being a, a much
funnier situation cause I can see,
I can make the, the woman's somehow
feel guilty for doing what she's doing.
I guess. I don't know, riff
on it. That's more fun.
But as far as the guy
heckling you after the show,
cause he didn't have the balls to do
it during the show was just sad and it
always makes me feel like that person
actually wanted to be a comedian.
They just never had the balls to do it.
And I'm watching the death of a dream.
Um Wow. That was dark. Okay.
Question number three is a he slash she
a bad comedian if they tried to talk to
the audience. I've noticed
in the last few years.
The worst comics are the ones that
base their comedy comedy on. Hi,
where are you from so they
can goof on the audience.
Oh wait a minute. Fucking seen
doubling so they can goof on.
The audience are the worst comics.
No, that wasn't me. That was him.
He wrote a bad sentence. Sick.
Even the last time I saw you learn
southern California, the Improv,
the two people before you kept trying to
find ways to make fun of the people in
the audience as a comic.
Do you think that this is a
sign that they are a bad comic?
I would think it would turn everyone else
else off because they are too worried
about being talked to.
Next one time I was watching a taping of
Frazier in La and 90% of the people got
up because the comic in the stands
with us kept ripping on everyone.
First of all, that's fucking hilarious.
The guy doing the audience warm up was
in between takes of Frazier was just
going, what do you guys,
a bunch of fucking Douche bags
and 90% of the crowd left.
Um, I don't want to be
a contender, but, uh,
I dunno about 90% been
like, just like 30%.
I would think if 90% of the studio
audience walked out at some point,
somebody with a clipboard and a headset
woulda walked over to the comic and when
would have been like, hey dude, why don't
you fucking tone it down a little bit?
Okay.
Kelsey Grammer's getting a little pissed
because 90% of the crowd has left.
Can you stop calling?
Calling him con, you know,
I know what you're saying though. Um,
what do I think as far as
people working with the,
on the audience? Yeah, I
definitely know what you mean.
There's definitely guys who don't have
enough jokes. So then they go, hey,
where are you from? What do
you do? Little that job sucks.
But then there's other guys I see fuck
with the crowd and they're brilliant at
it. Um, I would just basically say,
if you don't have any material and
you suck at playing to the crowd,
then yeah, you suck at it, then
you suck as a comic. Absolutely.
But if you're good at it
and that's your thing,
I don't think there's anything
wrong with him. Jesus Christ.
I answered that like
Hillary Clinton. Well,
I think it could be a good thing
and a bad thing. Oh, whatever.
Just fucking elect me. Um, all right.
Has she given up yet? Jesus Christ.
She's like one of the fucking,
she just won't tap out. She's
like one of the Gracies.
They got like a fucking arm bend all
back. I still think I'm doing good.
I think I'm going to
win. I'll say something.
That's the one thing I've
learned about this election.
I have learned that I completely
do not give a shit about race.
I really don't. Black, white,
Puerto Rican. I don't give a fuck.
If you make sense, I
will vote for you. Right.
But my hatred of women,
whoo. It's fucking unreal.
I don't hate women. It's just
that, that's fucking voice.
Good Lord. And you know, they,
they got to bring it down.
The problem is, is women,
they raise their voice up cause they
tried to do what the guys do guys,
when they raised their voice and
has a commanding sound to it.
Women when they raise their voice up,
they sound like a fucking seagull.
So what she needs to do is deliver
her speeches and a middle range,
maybe even drop it down to a whisper
a little bit. And I swear to God,
that's where the female voice has
power, medium voice to a whisper.
It can make a Deckard. You
know, you'd pick sides. I Dunno,
you're not thinking clearly you're gonna
fucking vote for, but when you, again,
when you're fucking way up there, people
are not going to hear your message.
I talk more shit on this fucking
thing. All right, the last question.
Here we go, then I'm going to get out
of here. Question number four. Bill,
you spoke about us, uh, going home
with you. You know, hearing you,
what all this is last week's podcast.
When I parked my car in
the garage and all, yeah,
we heard you walk up the steps, close
the garage door, which made me think,
uh, what's your take on stalkers?
Celebrity stockers, if you will?
Uh, she like insulting me. They're
celebrity starkers if you will,
celebrity in quotes.
God knows I love the eighties
doesn't count as being a celebrity,
which it doesn't. You're right. Okay.
I'm celebrity stockers if you will.
Have you ever had one? If you did, would
you be flattered or freak the fuck out?
Uh, okay. Um, uh, no. Yeah.
Obviously who the fuck wants to
be stopped? You know what I mean?
I don't really, I mean,
I wouldn't want to be stopped by
the hottest chick on the planet.
That's how frightening stockers are.
Because no matter how good looking the a,
they have that crazed, um,
I always think that, that,
that fatal attraction, and
I'm not going to be ignored,
Michael or whatever his fucking
character's name was a right,
then you know what he should done when,
whenever I see that movie
fatal attraction, she's like,
I'm not going to be ignored. And she
sort of leans her head down a little bit.
I always wanted him to just
hit her with like a fucking,
just a right cross from a
fucked up angle. Like A,
like Roy Jones member used to throw
the punches from those weird angles.
Maybe do like that little rooster
hop and just fucking crack.
You know, there, there's your
attention. Oh look at me.
I'm like dice clay the end of
this fucking thing. Why am I here?
It's just brutal. Why? Why am I lashing
out at women here in the end of this?
This is, this is dumb. Okay. Uh,
just cause I'm not going to vote for
Hillary Clinton doesn't mean I hate all
women.
I just hate the sound of the
female voice in the high register.
I think that that's what it is. Anyways,
let me finish answering this question and
then I'll get the fuck outta here. Um,
yeah, that is, that is my thing. Yet
stockers freaked me the fuck out. Um,
I don't mind people who are really,
you know, who come out to the show.
I've had a couple of people come out to
show and made tee shirts and that kind
of thing and they act a little zany.
That doesn't bug me. But you know,
later on that night I don't, you know,
roll over in bed and all of a sudden
they're hovering outside my hotel window.
Yeah, that would obviously
freak me out. Um, yeah,
I don't think anybody finds
that flattering. Okay.
I'm taking a very serious tone now all
of a sudden and I'm starting to get
scared. Okay. You happy? That's what
your question did to me. Alright,
I'm going to go put on my chin up
bar. Okay. That's what I'm doing.
And I'm actually going to buy a piece
of rope down at the hardware store that
I'm going to hang from the fucking thing
and I'm going to be able to fucking
climb up that son of a bitch. And I
don't want you thinking we'll bill.
It's the fucking, I mean what are you
gonna get? Like six feet of rope? No,
this is what you do. You do get
that amount of rope. Put your fuck.
You actually get more cause you
want to be able to tie it up,
but you sit on the floor, okay? With
your legs, straight out l shape.
And then you pull yourself
up just with the arms.
And I'm telling you if
you can fucking do that.
My goal is by November to fucking glue
10 nightstands and put them on top of
each other. And that's how I'm going
to end my shows. I need a hook people.
Okay, I'm going to climb right up
the fucking thing right out the roof.
Get on a helicopter by one of those old
pan-am ones and slide the fuck out of
the Gig. And that's how I'm going
to end it every fucking time.
I'm gonna do a big dramatic way,
right as I go through the ceiling of a
funny bone. All right, and that's it.
There you go. That's the podcast for
the week. Please, uh, please keep, uh,
sending me the questions. Please keep
asking me or giving me advice or whatever.
And uh, I will talk to you guys next
week. Everybody have a great week.
I'm a Carolina this week on
Thursday, Saturday and Sunday.
Friday I'm flying back to La Cause I
have to do a stand up on the spike TV
awards show. Um, next weekend,
the following weekend,
there'll be a good nights comedy
club in North Carolina. Uh,
later on that month, the 19th through the
21st will be at the punchline and, uh,
Atlanta, Georgia had Atlanta. And uh,
I don't know where the fuck
I'm going to be after that.
I just put up a of Miami, Florida date.
What else do I got coming up?
I got some dates in September.
I got Austin and October.
Just go to [inaudible] dot com check of
them out my DVD and my comedy special.
They're all coming out in
September that Jim Norton,
HBO down and dirty with Jimmy Norton.
That's also coming out in September.
And I'll let you guys know next week
when the Spike TV awards thing is coming
out. All right. That's it. Everybody
have a good week. Thanks for listening.
[inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible].